this video is brought to you by Ray Khan
hello wisecrack Helen here beaming to
you from the comforts of my apartment a
lot of people talk about being
productive during quarantine writing
books making short films reading all the
classics and hooped in calculus but I
have them all beat because during this
time I have immersed myself in the
greatest cultural catalogue of them all
Netflix
I have studied everything this great
purveyor of entertainment has put out
but there's one show I was most excited
to sit on my couch and kill half a day
watching space force the show seemingly
had everything going for it its creator
Greg Daniels had already made it not one
but two modern TV classics plus it
featured an amazing cast
Steve Carell John Malkovich Jane Lynch
Fred Willard Lisa Kudrow Ben Schwartz
and Patrick Warburton paired with a
ridiculous premise I was so hopeful and
then this just a dog pile of bad press
and I don't think it was just reviewers
being out of touch this show is in my
very scientific and not at all arbitrary
opinion bad
not exactly bright bad but still a
colossal disappointment I let you down
it left me wondering how could so many
talented people produce such a misfire
how did it tried-and-true formula go so
wrong let's find out in this wisecrack
edition on space force what went wrong
but before we get into it I want to give
a shout out to Ray Khan if you're
thinking about jumping on the Bluetooth
bandwagon now's the time to take the
lead one of the greatest hesitations for
me was earbud design I don't like the
hardshell earbuds because they always
fall out of my ears so easily but Ray
Khan earbuds come with different sized
gel tips so you can get the most
comfortable fit for your ear they're
snug compact and grey discreet on top of
a great fit they're more affordable
coming in and about half the price of
other premium Wireless brands on the
market and you don't have to compromise
on quality because they sound amazing
Rane Khan earbuds are perfect from
working from home working out or just
doing chores around the house when you
need to listen to music or podcast for
hours the everyday e25
is their best model yet with six hours
of playtime seamless bluetooth pairing
more bass and a compact design that
gives you a nice noise isolating fit
check them out now by going to buy recon
comm slash wisecrack or by clicking the
link in the description when you use the
link in the description you'll get 15%
off your order now back to the show
first a quick recap of the series the TV
series presents a fictionalized account
of the u.s. military's newest branch the
space force as it tries to get boots on
the moon by 2024
Steve Carell stars as General Mark
naired a hard-nosed general appointed to
lead it neared constantly has to balance
the demands of his chest thumping White
House superiors with those of his
scientific team led by Adrian Mallory
who questions if it's logically or even
ethically possible to get back to the
moon on such a tight timeframe making
matters even worse naren's family life
is quickly spiraling out of control his
wife is in prison and his teenage
daughter resents him for being a
workaholic faced with both professional
and personal uncertainty there's only
one place where naired can find relief
[Music]
space force at its heart gives us two TV
shows in one half-hour --is-- package
first a wacky office sitcom I love the
office and Parks and Rec and second a
political satire in the vein of V but by
constantly straddling this line space
force doesn't quite succeed as either so
let's break down how it fails on both
counts part 1 the workplace sitcom since
the advent of television the workplace
sitcom has provided an easy to shoot
setting for a group of eccentrics to
gather round and crack wise from
McHale's Navy to taxi
- Cheers - Ally McBeal to Archer the
workplace has served as a backdrop for
various characters to both come together
and clash their personality differences
providing conflict for each episode
because these corporate bag mantras only
$630 for my goddamn flex account in
comedy a geographic and historical guide
scholar Maurice Charney uses Cheers as
the prototypical example of the
workplace sitcom rights it is the most
ritualized sitcom format as it relies on
the repetition of a setting of each
character's traits and of each set of
conflicts and alliances it presented a
set of highly ritualized characters
whose personality traits were extremely
fixed and who interacted with one
another in the same ways each week each
episode of chairs is structured pretty
much exactly the same revolving around
bartender Sam Malone as he tends bar and
deals with patrons and employees the
workplace aka the bar became idealized
not necessarily because of the job
itself but because no matter the problem
each character could always rely on the
people there to have their backs Sam was
always willing to lend an ear to coach
Diane Carla cliff norm and Frasier just
take it from the cheers theme song the
same was true with other workplace
comedies of the era and of those that
preceded shears on Ally McBeal it was
the law firm on taxi the garage dispatch
center however as television aged the
depiction of the workplace on sitcoms
became far darker take Greg Daniels
breakout adaptation of the office the
workplace became an existential prison
and the shared experiences characters
bonded over when they bonded or centered
around their incompetent and incredibly
offensive boss Dunder Mifflin is a
complete dead end for each character
Jim the everyman hero of the series
hates his job openly stating that well
if this were my career I'd have to throw
myself in front of a train aside from
the occasional light of an office
romance Dunder Mifflin is marked by
soul-crushing monotony this here is a
run out the plot situation just upstairs
in season two's the office Olympics we
see how each employee copes with their
pointless jobs
crafting elaborate games for themselves
just to pass the time and Dunder Mifflin
unlike the bar of cheers doesn't seem to
bring these eccentrics together it
divides them well be eventually
about-face later in the show
much of the early seasons of the office
deal with the antagonistic relationship
between coworkers for instance in season
ones the Alliance after rumors of
downsizing begin to spread people at the
office begin to form secret pacts
against one another later in the series
when the employees dare to even think
about joining together and unionizing
the Dunder Mifflin higher-ups squashed
the camaraderie
threatening to dissolve the branch
completely if there is even a whiff of
unionizing in this branch I can
guarantee you the branch will be shut
down like that Dunder Mifflin is
repeatedly shown to be a toxic
environment one in which stupidity and
boorishness are promoted look no further
than Jim's boss Michael Scott who has
proven time and time again to be an
impediment to productivity Michael
claims to have his employees best
interests at heart yet whenever he feels
challenged he immediately sells them out
guys downstairs are thinking about
forming a union and they have a union if
you've ever wondered why he hates Toby
so much it's likely because he's the
only person who could challenge his
antics maybe you still can't make fun of
people for race or gender or sexual
orientation religious who look who let
the lemonhead into the room or consider
the time when Jim takes a private
meeting with the CFO and Michael
mistakenly thinks this means Jim must be
angling for his job to ensure he doesn't
get fired
Michael bad-mouths Jim to his higher-ups
thereby sabotaging Jim's promotion
constant office distraction spends way
too much time in reception antagonizing
other salesmen not at all
how bad is Dunder Mifflin it's so bad
that employment lawyer Julie Elgar even
started a vlog chronicling all the
actionable offenses that occur at the
company and it's over 30 pages long in
its later years the office softened some
of these edges many characters ended up
marrying their co-workers or forming
unlikely friendships of one another yet
Dunder Mifflin itself always remained a
destructive environment in the offices
finale it's telling that for a vast
majority of the characters their happy
ending involves getting away from this
corporate Hellmouth not quite as
cheerful as well Cheers
but also not quite as nightmarish as the
office space forces workplace setting
exist somewhere between the two visions
on one hand the space for space is
located in the desolate wasteland of
Colorado a place where the only sign of
life is a single convenience store
patron by meth gangs it's so bad that
when naired first tells his wife where
they're moving she immediately breaks
down in tears
Colorado Mike Dunder Mifflin is depicted
as a dead end for narrative his family
when the series jumps ahead a year in
the opening episode naren's wife is now
literally behind bars for unexplained
reasons and his daughter has no friends
or job prospects to speak of naired
himself feels trapped his momentous
promotion to a four-star general is
quickly undercut as he becomes the
four-star general of a branch considered
a joke amongst his peers
well it's not bull crap for spaceforce
first time with your keister in the hot
seat my beer last
and yet the space force base stands in
strong contrast to these immediate
surroundings hidden behind a rocky
mountain the base is a luxurious
high-end campus spacious green and
pristine heck they even have an ice
cream stand
so is naired stuck in a dead-end job or
is this the opportunity of a lifetime
well space force can't really decide one
way or the other
sometimes the series is very critical of
nerds job and his attempts to militarize
space after space forces satellite is
cut apart by a rival Chinese satellite
naired proposes that they use a bomb to
push the broken pieces back together
what about a bomb in my experience with
the Air Force that was very often the
right answer very very often of course
Malory shoots the idea down because a
bomb won't work in the vacuum of space
alright a big [ __ ] bomb that was my
first instinct anyway that's no better
shockwaves it's a fast basis of vacuum
thus the idea of implementing
traditional military techniques is
depicted not only as wrong but is
completely absurd in the office Daniels
really explored what it meant to be in a
dying pointless industry a place for
your average employee can only ask the
basic question why and it seems like a
similar opportunity with space force
whereas the office explored the waning
paper industry space quartz explores the
reigning of American hegemony and there
you need help getting back the Chinese
what they did you sideline a little
ground-and-pound whatever I don't know
let me know Marines at your disposal and
even if the space course itself isn't
obsolete it certainly seems frivolous to
many the show takes some strides in this
direction basically reducing the
conflict between China and the US as a
childish pissing contest mostly
involving vandalism but the series
pretty quickly backs off the u.s.
actually is in a military standoff with
the Chinese for space dominance Daniel's
even stated that the more he researched
space force the more sense the
department actually made the more
research that we did into it the more it
didn't feel like the problem was all in
the heads of people in the United States
because there's people in Russia and
China and elsewhere scrambling to get up
there unlike dunder-mifflin where the
job was in and of itself
pointless working at the space force is
treated as an integral and worthwhile
vocation so the series is stuck in a
strange middle ground both highly
critical of the militarization of space
yeah and also treating it like a
necessity which inherently makes that
tire more difficult to be fair this
middle ground was masterfully tread in
Parks and Rec a show that skewered
dysfunctional local politics
I think the slogan should be Pawnee home
of crackers the oranges goldfish in
Indiana while ultimately championing
local politician Leslie for her
perseverance but the viewpoint of the
show unlike space force was clear the
democratic process is messy overly
bureaucratic and dominated by rich
idiots but we can still try to turn a
giant pit into a park it just might take
a few years we present the crown jewel
of Pawnee even more space force is
missing a key ingredient that made the
office Parks and Rec cheers and pretty
much every sitcom ever made work the
straight man or woman on Cheers
it was bartender Sam Malone for the
office Jim Halpert for Parks and Rec
mark and Ann these characters served as
audience surrogates for the series the
every man or woman reacting to the crazy
high jinks that happen around them on
the office white Michael and Angela
could be as insane and off-color as
needed but then you could always count
on the camera panning over to Jim
shaking his head and amusement
however with space force there really
isn't the traditional straight man
Merritt is technically our entry way
into the show the point-of-view
character yet space force constantly
distances us from him by depicting him
as a blustering idiot it's nerd that
tries to use a monkey to fix a broken
satellite and later accuses one of his
scientists of being a Chinese spy based
solely on his race chan chan is mine
number two I consider him above
suspicion all right so we've got yuri
baxter chan in these instances the
series cuts to Malkovich's adrian
mallory as he shakes his head and
amusement so is Mallory the everyman not
quite while he balances naired he loses
pretension Mallory is even more
eccentric than there'd
self-centered hothead set off by anyone
who doesn't take him seriously without a
straight man or woman the characters on
space force constantly fear between
oscillating extremes
sometimes nerrit is upheld as a beacon
of virtue someone the audience should
sympathize with and relate to the
founder of the space force that's going
to be me while other times he does this
you overheated Arana CLE this is a
problem Greg Daniels has dealt with
before on Parks and Rec sure mark and
Ann offered balance to Leslie's antics
but they weren't quite central to the
show just take it from Daniels himself
but Parks and Rec didn't really hit
until season two the big adjustment was
that Amy Poehler was funnier being the
smart center of a crazy world didn't
somebody whose character flaws cause
their own problems I would say by three
or four episodes we had fixed that I
think personally it wasn't until Parks
and Rec created a straight woman out of
Amy Poehler's less than note that the
show was able to find its footing and
even when she got a little too into
binders and waffles she was grounded
with the down-to-earth Ness of someone
like and however space force still
hasn't found that balance yet but this
balance is only half the story because
besides being a workplace comedy space
force is also trying to be a political
satire part to political satire just as
space forces wishy-washy about its
depiction of workplace antics it's also
wishy-washy about its satire according
to Daniel's space force is supposed to
be a commentary on how the idealism of
space has been co-opted by militaristic
nationalism what was once about the
idealistic pursuit of human exploration
has instead become all about national
and military dominance according to
Daniel's I think the show's feeling is
more that it's too bad we're now in this
new phase of space exploration where it
isn't about doing it for all mankind in
some moments space force really nails
the satirical point we need to add back
hard we can bomb big bomb little bomb
who's smart bomb stupid
- one for every occasion yet at the same
time space force constantly pulls its
punches on a biting satire like veep the
show takes no prisoners every subject
every political movement is open to
ridicule whether liberal or conservative
rather than attacking a political
faction the show puts the entire
political process on blast people need
to think he's in here leading but he's
not he is according to the room where
I'd put up space force on the other hand
wants to be a satire of America's
militaristic nationalism without letting
itself be too mean to the institution at
the center of it as such space force
lacks any specific perspective
militarizing space is both absurd and a
necessity general naired is both a great
man and a total buffoon the job is both
noble and a dead end space force wants
to have it every which way and in the
process it says nothing at all
just look at how the series treats its
central antagonistic relationship mark
naired vs. Adrian Mallory in many ways
this relationship is a mirror image of
our favorite local government Odd Couple
in Parks and Rec the central
antagonistic relationship was between
Leslie Knope and Ron Swanson Leslie
represented the textbook liberal she
earnestly believed that her public
service she could help fix the wrongs of
the world and build a better tomorrow
when we worked here together we fought
scratched and clawed to make people's
lives a tiny bit better that's what
public service is all about however
Leslie's boss Ron represented the
textbook libertarian he believed the
government should be virtually
non-existent my idea of a perfect
government is one guy who sits in a
small room at a desk and the only thing
he's allowed to decide is who to nuke as
such Ron supported minimizing the parks
and rec departments output by hiring
people who would do as little as
possible but I like Tom he doesn't do a
lot of work around here
he shows zero initiative he's not a team
player he's never wanted to go that
extra mile Tom is exactly what I'm
looking for in a government employee now
naturally you would expect Leslie and
Ron
but heads and yes oftentimes they did me
want more pointless social programs
yummy yum yum but as the series grew the
show focused less on the antagonism
between the two and more on their
unlikely friendship
despite their political differences Ron
and Leslie genuinely cared for one
another and helped each other both
professionally and personally
as such Parks and Rec used Ron and
Leslie's relationship to present an
idealized form of government one in
which people from opposing party lines
could still come together to get things
done what does take it from Amy Poehler
the show is about the fact that there's
a lot of people who work together who
have nothing in common except for the
fact that they work together that really
describes to me national politics people
who have nothing in common except for
the fact that they work together and
have to find a way to work together and
make change happen
similarly on spaceforce Meriden mallory
represent opposite ends of the
ideological spectrum Mallory embodies a
kind of smug liberal intelligentsia
whereas naired
is you're ignorant and blustery military
man I am what used to be known in
America as a man but unlike Parks and
Rec space force doesn't use this
contrasting relationship to comment on
any larger issues instead it's just kind
of all over the place sometimes Mallory
is used as an obstacle for Nair to
overcome for instance in the pilot
Mallory keeps trying to under handedly
postpone their satellite launch saving
the scientific dangers of doing so
prematurely but by the end of the
episode
Naren follows his gut and successfully
launches the satellite proving Mallory's
objections to be unfounded however in
later episodes
Marin's gut military instincts are a
liability and it's Mallory's cautious
reasoning that saves the day in episode
Naren is only able to defeat the rival
Air Forces team in a test skirmish
because of Mallory's deus ex machina
code space force seems unsure of what
side it's on Mallory's intellectualism
or Naren jingoism
it basically becomes a toss-up each
episode on who will be proven right as
if since naired won the day last episode
now it's Mallory's turn to do so and if
the ultimate point is that both men end
up rubbing off on one another creating a
new middle ground well space force
doesn't present that traditional arc
either instead by the final episodes
both men
shift perspectives out of the blue after
spaceforce discovers that the Chinese
have established a base on the moon it's
Mallory who thinks they need to take a
more decisive militaristic approach what
if your friend who runs the Navy were to
move a Carrier Strike Group or no to
Carrier Strike groups into the South
China Sea
whereas naired wants to try a more
diplomatic route and speak to the
Chinese general sometimes it's important
that cooler heads prevail
thus the characters don't even attempt
to come to a middle ground
they simply switch ideologies based on
well plus the closest space force comes
to making a clear political point
happens in the last episode after naired
is ordered by his White House superiors
to burn the Chinese moon base to the
ground he enlists Mallory to help defy
this order naired then gives the
following speech forget how bad polio
was people stop taking vaccines forget
how bad world wars are people start
puffing out their chests the real enemy
is arrogance this seems to be the
ultimate point of space force that both
Mallory and nerds arrogance often blind
them to the correct course of action if
only both characters and the world at
large could put their egos aside then
the real work could be done and yet
nothing in the previous nine episodes
shows this point to be true because it's
nerds arrogance in the pilot that his
gut knows better than science that saves
the day and it's Mallory's perceived
intellectual superiority that allows the
space force to defeat the Air Force in
their skirmish all space horse has
proven up to now is that narrowed and
Mallory should be staunch in their
beliefs in case there accidentally right
ultimately space force twists itself so
much to appease every side that it
forgets to say anything interesting or
really anything much at all however it's
not all doom and gloom
the first seasons of The Office and
Parks and Rec were similarly fraught
with issues before reversing course to
become two of the most beloved modern
sitcoms so if anyone could write this
ship especially with such a great cast
it's Greg Daniels but what do you think
are we just cranky because space force
has it lived up to the greatness of its
predecessors or is it legitimately bad
let us know what you think in the
comments
big big thanks to our awesome patrons
for supporting our channel and podcast
and as always thanks for watching peace
[Music]